hey everybody this is gonna be my
episode 6 Q&A video just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet
lots of Assyrian questions lots of
questions about the night king maybe
knowing that they were coming and laying
a trap for them where that Home Depot
was where they bought that giant chain
lots of endgame questions so here we go
first one
Damian asks episode 7 question for you
Game of Thrones has consistently used
episodes 8 & 9 to deliver the most
exciting battles while episode tens have
often been used for staging the next
season
do you believe they'll continue this
formula and we'll get one of the best
finale episodes yet well I don't know
about best finale episodes yet that's
usually a matter of opinion it just
depends on how you feel about the season
in general most of you notice that
they've slowly turned the show from a
more Game of Thrones II conversational
character based show to a more action
based show where characters are just
running around there's not quite as much
dialogue less interpersonal politicking
and more plot based big action
set-pieces so I think that this final
episode will be like previous seasons
where you have a lot of big character
twists but not necessarily big action
set pieces but there will be a couple
big WTF moments but most of them will be
things that happen between the main
characters next one Jonathan asks do you
think that Arya is actually playing
Littlefinger this is probably one of the
biggest questions that I got but I think
it's a little more complicated than that
I think a lot of people are looking at
this final scene together especially
when she gives Sansa the Valyrian dagger
as a sign that she trusts her and maybe
she's been doing this on an elaborate
ruse to make Littlefinger think that
she's played into his trap but the
reason that I don't think that's the
case is because there wasn't really any
moment with bran that foreshadowed that
he was going to tell Sansa and Arya some
information that would cause them to
plot against him think about the way the
TV show beats you in the face with
foreshadowing early in episode 4 we see
a scorpion spear drogon which is
foreshadowing for the episode 6 night
king javelin moment the show wanted to
let you know that dragons could be
killed they could be hurt in how it
would be accomplished like it has to be
a really sharp projectile moving really
fast they could pierce their hide so
while we've seen with the Littlefinger
plot is that brand just blurts
information out and he probably knows
things
that little finger has done but they
haven't had any conversation about brand
revealing that information Tucson
Centauri yet he just said here's the
dagger you can have it I'm a [ __ ] it
won't do me any good had there been a
couple lines of dialogue or a moment
where brand said chaos is a ladder to
Arya and Sansa that would have implied
that they knew what Littlefinger had
done next one dark row gasps do you
think that Theon will die or Yara do you
think the Gendry will get storms end and
then something about ghosts maybe dying
off screen because of the way the show
is kind of messing with that character
just going down the list I'll start with
Theon I think that he's gonna be the one
to take down you're on but Yara will die
there's this big arc happening with
Theon's character he's slowly becoming
more and more human that conversation
with Jon he seems pretty lucid if
anyone's gonna kill you're on it's gonna
be him and that'll be him sort of
reclaiming a form of his manhood even if
it's not literally reclaiming his
manhood but as for again dree storms in
now that we know that he's still alive
yeah you know Arya won't have to kill
Jon for mistakenly choosing to go north
of the wall and take him along
and now the Jon's king of the north
Daenerys his Queen presumptive you have
two monarchs that can legitimize Gendry
make him Gendry Baratheon and grant him
storms and after the war is over so just
based on the fact that they're keeping
him alive I feel like they're gonna try
and use him in a meaningful way even if
it's not that many scenes during season
eight and they'll at least offer him
storms and we'll see if he chooses to
accept it because if arya doesn't want
to be a lady of a castle and you want
the fan fiction ending for the two of
them then what would she do if he became
a lord and wanted to take her along too
she might have some problems with that
but I think it just depends on what you
think end game is for Arya as for the
ghost one he's still alive even if the
show doesn't bring him back he's at
Winterfell right now it's more of a
creative decision just to focus more on
the Dragons because John is gonna be a
dragon rider now so I think their choice
is more of an economic one that they're
not gonna worry about working him into
scenes they'll have some very brief
moment just to let you know what's up
with him even if somebody only mentions
him in passing like Oh ghost is really
wondering when you're gonna come back
John just as a way to let us know that
he's still alive
next one Shakir s so you're asking if
the knight King had a plan for everyone
like it seemed like he had the chains
ready to go like he was trying to bait
them so that he could get one
the Dragons I actually do like that idea
just because it explains a couple of the
plot holes even if that wasn't the
intention of the producers and the
writers I really don't think that they
planned ahead of time but I do think it
would be smarter if they had said that
the night king was trying to bait them
into that situation because he could
sense the Dragons and wanted to use one
of them to help bring the wall down so
that he could bring the army of the Dead
south next one Samantha asked how did
they get those big-ass chains around
bazarian to pull them out of that deep
lake so there are a lot of questions
about what White's are capable of like
can they actually swim the simplest
explanation is probably the best so we
can assume they got the boat chains from
hardhome drugged themselves and then the
night king just forces a bunch of them
to drop down into the lake they sink to
the bottom wrap the chain around it and
then they start pulling it back up so I
do not think that they're capable of
swimming meaning that the ones that went
down to the bottom of the lake to wrap
the chain around his neck are still down
there walking around so he's thinning
the herd a little bit in the name of
getting that big dragon up so a little
bit of collateral damage there but it's
totally worth it because now he has an
undead dragon which is a huge upgrade
next question Mimi Cam's asks have you
heard about John's sword being alive
what are your thoughts on this I need
some closure so this is also one of the
biggest questions that people messaged
me about on Twitter or Facebook YouTube
I don't think that there's anything
super special going on with that sword
if you're not sure what people are
talking about there was this moment
where John goes under the water and long
claws sitting there the camera zooms in
and you see the eye on the pommel there
gets splashed with water and then it
seemingly turns black as if the eye is
opening so people took that as a
metaphor for something or foreshadowing
but what I actually think is happening
is that it only turned black because of
the splash of water and they chose not
to fix that in post production so I
think it's more of a continuity error
than foreshadowing or symbolism for
anything next question Ali asks why is
Sansa being summoned to King's Landing
the show acted like this was normal even
though sonses an escaped fugitive
suspected of killing Joffrey so yes I
think that salsa was correct and not
going to King's Landing but I think it's
more of a plot device to get all the
characters in the same place and that
dragon pit for the final episode this
this big moment of convergence that
they're working towards all these
characters that have been all over the
world are now going to be in the same
place at the same time but the problem
is is that you have the Winterfell
Littlefinger Sansa Arya brand plot so
for Sansa her arc this season has been
all about what's happening at Winterfell
so it'd be too weird to send her down to
King's Landing but they want
representation from the north so that's
why she's sending Brienne for her but
again it's one of those things where
they reverse engineered a moment like
they want to have everyone together so
how do they get everyone together so
there are a few minor plot holes because
jon is the representative of the north
he's already going to be there so why
would Cersei need somebody else from the
north to be there - next question
Natalie asks is there a chance for big
stark reunion including Jon and season 8
what do you think well I think you know
we just talked about Sansa I think
that's one of the big reasons for not
sending Sansa as well because they want
to push that stark reunion to season 8
but yeah I definitely think it's gonna
happen there's been this big thing this
season about keeping John away from
Winterfell while all of his brothers and
sisters that are still alive come back
so we can only assume that it's probably
gonna be some really touching moment but
I don't think that he's going to see
them or go back to Winterfell at least
till season 8 in most of what he needs
is a Dragonstone and if he's going to be
with Daenerys then he's probably gonna
stay there that's where they're
dragonglass mine is - so at this point
there is a good reason for him not to go
back next question joven asks gendry
together with sam's new secret recipe
we'll make new Valyrian swords and a
kick-ass new Valyrian hammer yeah that
was you know one of the consequences of
Gendry leaving his hammer behind and
then the Hound dropping it as they
escape he can totally make a new one now
this is more of those useful Gendry
things in season eight he's a great
blacksmith they have all this material
now you have Sam coming with all the
super specific knowledge about how to
make more sophisticated versions a
Valyrian steel bolt in a new scorpion
would be a good way to take care of
undead Viserion Nick's one Joseph's ass
can someone please tell me the season 8
script leak is fake so you may have seen
people have been talking about season 8
leaks there was a big hack so most
people are just trading on that there's
no big season 8 leak they don't even
start shooting till October there's no
footage to see the big problems that
there have been season 7 leaks so far so
people just assume now
that when someone says there's a season
8 league oh it must be true because all
these season 7 leaks happened so if you
hear people claiming to reveal plot of
season 8 it's just them trolling now you
can make a lot of assumptions based on
things that happen in episodes but at
this stage all season 8 stuff is just
prediction based so a really good
example of that is brand revealing Jon
Snow's parentage to him now he said in a
previous episode I need to talk to Jon
so we know that he's going to tell him
at some point so if someone says hey
season 8 leaked bran tells Jon it's not
a leak it's just the most obvious
prediction of all time
they said they were gonna have brand
revealed the information to Jon he
reveals it to him that's not a leak
that's just something that we would knew
happen eventually anyway but thank you
so much for submitting questions these
are always a ton of fun to do what'll
happen is this later this week I'll do
more mythology bonus videos so if you
have special requests just leave them in
the comments below
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Jessi Hernandez please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details you
can click here for the finale trailer
and you can click here for my episode
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
you